alors évidemment bonjour tous
aujourd'hui je suis avec pierre cros et
je suis chez qui accroche c'est dans la
chambre de mon cas l'auteur lâchant dit
je suis un mentaliste pas pierre cros
comme ça tu vois je suis par contre toi
peut-être qu'à mentalist et tu le sais
pas encore je suis en montre une semaine
mais pourrait trouve pas une deuxième
chaîne et demandai je suis sur le projet
d'une deuxième chaîne le mental cross
vraiment pas de preuve mais avec ds tous
les jours des jo de deux heures de mon
père est-ce que je peux prendre un des
livres de son colocataire 75 parce qu'il
est bon alors c'est nul c'est la
biographie de loana fascinant ok le but
du jeu pour moi ça va pas être de
deviner quelque chose que tu penses mais
de t'envoyer une pensée et que toi tu la
trouves comme internet comme exacts a
convoqué je peux passer par ce que je
vois c'est vrai on arrête peut s'arrêter
à ces deux minutes la vidéo et 2nd g
choisir quelque chose d'assez simple à
la gorge de trop compliqué blain ça m'a
un peu d'imagination ça va tu visualise
des choses faciles ou quoi ouais je suis
très visuel à coup moins alors ça ça
marche dans ce cas là tu vas imaginer
devant toi un grand b peur board
je vais t'envoyer mentalement un mot
assez simple quelque chose d'assez
simple qu'on peut dessiner assez faciles
manqués donc c'est en train de dessiner
la dans ta tête
je dessine ainsi d'accord quelque chose
d'assez classique ou parlant avec la cie
la barre haute
est ce que maintenant tu peux effacer le
dessin ou le rayer temps il faut juste
un chiffon tient froid qu'inversement et
tu l'écris en toute l'asie maintenant à
la place ce système est déjà en ligne un
bureau du groupe c'est dans ces grandes
fenêtres je vous fais rien voir quand
même vous même on doit ce n'est pas
dangereux
qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire la
troisième lettre baïdy l'asie côté météo
la soirée une maison regarde juste je te
fais voir avec mon doigt sur quoi je
n'étais et bien sûr maison là je te
bleus à faire du ricard
merci beaucoup merci l'échec de
mentalist il ya n'hésitez pas surtout à
vous abonner la chaîne de fabien olicard
et puis aussi un email et vous quelle
est la bonne à dire que la merci
beaucoup rendez vous demain à 17 heures
pour le prochain mentale blog châu